hey this is uh this is not the biggest
news but it's kind of funny and it
relates to a story we did so it was
months ago or maybe it was even a year
ago I took two DNA tests on ancestry.com
and on 23andme com and I sort of went
back and forth because I know about the
different concerns around DNA privacy
and data privacy and all of this other
stuff but I said you know what I think
it'll make a good segment I'm going to
take my DNA tests we're gonna have a DNA
expert a genealogist on the program to
analyze my DNA and lots of people in the
audience found it sort of funny that I
was determined to be 92% Ashkenazi
Jewish which was the highest percentage
that the DNA expert we brought on had
ever seen and anyone's DNA that he
reviewed in his lifetime doing DNA
analyses I was the most Jewish person I
don't know if it's a something something
to cheer about or something to be scared
about given the political climate right
now well based on a larger DNA sample
size and sort of fine-tuning the
algorithm over the weekend I got an
email from ancestry.com and they said
David great news we originally did your
DNA background on the basis of 3,000 DNA
samples and and sort of organizing them
and the data from them we now have
16,000 and more precise algorithms and
we have an updated analysis for you and
I am here today to tell you that
ancestry.com can now report that I am no
longer 92 percent Ashkenazi Jewish I am
wait for it 100%
Ashkenazi Jewish that's that's the new
determination this can't possibly be
good for me with the anti-semites who
watch the program and comment on YouTube
and send me those lovely love tweets
that I get every single that I can't
imagine that this is really going to
help me with them is it we will see if
producer Pat got an update on this and
follow-up maybe on the bonus show about
it but that that's the latest news and
interesting
before it actually seems like this is
really pretty good good data because my
original analysis was sort of vague in
terms of the regions of Europe where it
was more vague in terms of the regions
of Europe that my ancestors were from
and now that my Ashkenazi Jewish
ancestry has increased from 92 percent
to a hundred percent they've also
fine-tuned the map and it now is a map
that points to two specific areas that
at least based on my family's known
history are the areas in Europe that
that were from so I think this is
interesting and I know people will write
to me and they'll get mad they'll say
David how are you promoting these
services that are going to use your data
to do who knows what I've heard just
about everything suggested I get that
and quite frankly I've just calculated
that I'm more interested in having this
information than I am worried about how
they might use my data and that may be
incredibly short-sighted it may be
something that I someday regret and if
you think that's going to be the case
get in touch and let me know how that is
the case but for now I'm sort of happy
having this information today's show was
made possible in part by simple habit
comm slash Pakman at this point the
benefits of meditation have been pretty
clearly shown to be significant and
that's why I'm so excited that simple
habit is sponsoring the show which is a
guided meditation app that just won the
2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app I use the app myself all
you need is five to ten minutes a day
simple habit lets your brain go on a
quick vacation that it very likely
really needs maybe you've been thinking
about giving meditation a try you don't
know where to start simple habit is
really the perfect way to just jump
right into it great for beginners
equally useful for people with
meditation experience they've got quick
meditations for first thing in the
morning for falling asleep at night for
clearing your mind when you're stressed
meditations for decision-making for
getting motivated getting focused
getting creative hundreds and hundreds
to choose from they're designed and
recorded by well-known names in the
world of meditation and mindfulness and
you can track all of your progress
whatever time of day it is whatever mood
you're in there's probably a meditation
on simple habit that's perfectly suited
for whatever you're trying to accomplish
with meditation go check it out you can
try it free for seven days at simple
habit calm slash Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video